- [Voiceover] In the diagram at left,
I drew it up here above,
or I pasted up here,
line segment A D intersects B E,
and line segment A B, A B
is parallel to D E.
What is the length of side C E?
So we wanna figure out the length of side,
we wanna figure out
the length of side C E.
Now, it might jump out at you,
at least it looks like it immediately,
that triangle, the small
triangle on the left
is going to be similar to this
larger triangle on the right.
But let's feel good about that.
Let's prove that to ourselves.
And to help ourselves prove that,
we're gonna remind ourselves
that A B is parallel to D E.
And actually, to think
about that even more,
I'm gonna extend these
segments a little bit,
so that you can really start to see
that they are parallel lines,
and that we have a transversal,
or we have two transversals
that intersect those parallel lines.
All right, and I could keep,
if I wanted to extend this as a line,
I could keep going in both directions,
but the bottom line,
not to be punny about it,
is that these two things are parallel.
That is parallel to that.
And that's going to help us establish
that these two triangles are,
that these two triangles are similar.
Well, the first thing we know is,
look, this angle is vertical,
is a vertical angle with this angle,
so they're going to be congruent.
This angle right over here,
if you view segment B E as a transversal
of the two parallel lines,
that right over there is going to be
an alternate interior angle.
This is going to be an
alternate interior angle
to this angle right over here.
These are alternate interior,
alternate interior angles,
so they're going to be congruent.
If some of this sounds like Greek to you,
and you are not Greek,
I encourage you to watch
the videos on Khan Academy
of angles, of transversals,
and parallel lines.
And by the same argument,
if we look at A D as a transversal,
this angle right over,
well let me do that in a different color,
this angle, this angle right over here
is an alternate interior
angle with this one,
so they're going to be congruent.
But the whole point of
everything I just did
is to show that, look,
the three angles here
are congruent to the three angles here,
so these must be similar triangles.
And the reason why that's useful
is because if the two
triangles are similar,
then the ratio between corresponding sides
is going to be the same.
So, for example, the ratio of side C E,
so we could say the ratio,
the ratio of C E,
of the length of segment C E,
to say, to say, this side right over here,
so side, segment E D,
which has length 7.5,
is going to be equal to the ratio
of the corresponding side to C.
Look, C E is the side
opposite this green angle,
so if you go on this similar triangle,
opposite to this green angle,
that segment B C.
So it's going to be equal to the ratio
of the corresponding side, so 2.1,
in the other triangle,
to the corresponding side
of D E in the other triangle.
And this side is opposite this blue angle,
this, one of the vertical
angles right over here.
So the corresponding side over here
is going to be side B A.
So this is gonna be over 2.5.
So what would C E be equal to?
Well multiple ways to solve this,
but one way, we could just
multiply both sides by 7.5,
multiply both sides by 7.5.
Now, what's 7.5 divided by 2.5?
Well 75 divided by 25 would be three,
so 7.5 divided by 2.5 is three.
So it's going to be three,
so length of segment C
E is 2.1 times three.
So the length of segment
C E is going to be,
what is that?
6.3.
And if we look down here,
we see that that is indeed,
that is indeed on of the choices.